thank you so much for coming out tonight
let's talk about
uh the origins of marcel the show which
i remember uh as a shorts i used to be a
schwartz programmer for la film festival
so i remember this short very well
um came out in 2010 i think he played
sundance in 2011.
what
where did the original idea
for marcel come from
um it's one of those classic things
where when you're not trying to create
something you're just having fun it
blossoms into something unexpected uh a
friend had asked me to create a video
for his stand-up comedy show when i
lived in new york that was just a local
live stand-up show and i had forgotten
until like the day before jenny
had been doing this little voice that
became marcel's voice um and changed
very little like from what you hear now
because we were sharing a hotel room for
our friend's wedding with five other
people and she felt very cramped and was
like doing this tiny voice to express
like how cramped she felt so with like
one day to make this video i was like oh
god can i interview you is it i'm gonna
like make an animation or whatever and
then i
i think like went to the craft store
bought supplies
mocked something up
mocked a character up and and um like
animated it and edited it and screened
it within like 48 hours
so
and it's three minutes right the
original three minutes
um and so did you already know how to do
animation had you done an animated film
no if you've seen the first short you
can tell i don't know how to animation
how long does a three minute
stop motion animation take
uh
kirsten could probably answer the
question better than me but but for me i
mean the original marcel was like a
solid block so he didn't have any points
of articulation at all so that could be
done like kind of quickly
um but it ranges depending on the
complexity so um
so it's you made three marcel shorts and
two books
and so from from 2010 to now what was
happening in between
just life
um how did how did nick and kirsten come
on did you always envision doing a
future version of this was that
something that took a while to sort of
figure out
i had always envisioned doing a feature
version of this but but
jenny and i were like very green when
the short came out and it sort of blew
up on the internet
and we took a lot of meetings at like
big studios and networks but it was very
clear like one of them recommended that
we partner him with ryan reynolds and
they fight crime and it was like
it just was very clear that they were
they were interested in kind of grafting
marcel onto a more familiar like tent
pole
marcel could be part of the mcu right
now that's right
are you really sad you turned that down
yeah well then when i saw detective
pikachu i was like we got pitch detected
oh my god
um but i want to ask you because so
uh marcel the first short went went
viral um and i know that kirsten had the
same experience with with her film high
stranger i don't know if you've seen the
amazing high stranger it will haunt me
for the rest of my life
um
i wanted to know because i've never
heard anybody talk about it what happens
for you when something goes viral do
like people just start calling and
trying to get meetings with you
does anything real happen
i don't know what your experience was
the internet has changed so much since
marcel went viral that i don't
i think kirsten you might have had like
the last video to go organically viral
the last short film i don't know i mean
yeah i mean for me i definitely got
meetings but the funny thing i don't
know if you found had the same
experience but like the funny thing for
me is like a lot of people
wrongly assume that like you go viral
and somehow that equates to like instant
money yeah yeah and it's like no i don't
i don't get any money for a viral movie
i just like got meetings which you know
could eventually translate into money
once you do more work you know for those
people or whatever but uh yeah yeah i
think i'm one of the people that thinks
as soon as you go viral it just
translates
into cash coming in the coolest
i guess like it might for some people
like i i know like tick tock influencers
make money on sponsored content but then
you got to make sponsored comments you
got to make sponsor content yeah i think
probably kirsten and i
probably if you have a career in mind
that you want to pursue and then
something goes viral that's not really
in your wheelhouse then you don't make a
lot of money because you're like i'm
doing other stuff it's like that that
guy on the skateboard who's like
drinking the orange juice to the
stevie next song
[Music]
is he a millionaire right now a
billionaire
um so complete with mac i interrupted
you answering my own question which was
how did this eventually go from being a
short to a feature so go ahead okay so
we had those original meetings and they
were just like okay this is obviously
not the process it's not how we made it
we're not going to be able to as like
newbies to hollywood like be able to
make a movie that we actually like this
way and i certainly felt like
we were gonna have to like you know it
might be a longer we said no to all
those offers and um i think it was the
right choice ultimately but the right at
the time it wasn't clear was the right
choice but
uh
we were just like okay so we're gonna
have to like do this from the ground up
and meet the right people both like
uh creatively and financially to make to
make the
movie that was clear to me at least and
to jenny i think too
was supposed to be like the marcel movie
that really focused you know like a
portrait of him that really
um treated him with dignity and took him
seriously and wasn't trying to like
you know blow it out and have him go
like
save paris or whatever
yeah i mean and and i came on also in
like 2014 so i will say like in that
time right in that time between like
there wasn't that you know i think you
guys like there's not much of a gap like
we've been working on this for a really
long time that's totally true well yeah
i was going to say
my impression is that's that any kind of
animation but especially stop-motion
animation takes a hell of a long time so
yeah um how long
from when you s
so
with stop motion
when you sit down to write a script
how is that different than if you were
just sort of like writing
a regular movie
with all humans in it
well you have a lot more control with
animation because you can record audio
write a scene record the audio
edit the scene and then be like oh it's
not very good
and then you can re-record it which is
great but it's a nightmare also and we
worked on the audio play for
three years
before we animated a single frame before
we got to we were sort of simultaneously
writing and recording audio and
eventually doing storyboards me and
kirsten like drawing frames and so wow
it was this like soup of
content that
nick and i both come from editing we met
as like editors on a
very weird tv show and uh
sorry that made it sound like it was
like it's not porn it's not
um and so we were you know we were
editing
probably as much as we were writing and
like doing all these kind of other
things that were
made up the brain trust sort of
yeah yeah this shows brad city isn't it
what's that
no no it's not fraternity yeah what's
the weird show
oh yeah it's not broad city no it was
this is a stoner puppet cooking show
called
called food party it was on ifc for one
minute
i wanted i didn't know this oh it's a
great show everybody's reading that i
highly recommend it everyone's looking
that up on their phones right now yeah
um so
okay so you spent
three years just recording the audio
and then you were ready to animate and
then
not so fast
please slow down we have seven years to
walk through step by step oh okay
and then also the pandemics in there
this is gonna take a long time you gotta
i hope you brought a snack
i i just the i think that it breaks down
to like three years of writing and
recording audio then we were like cool
this movie works oh we had already done
the storyboard so we had an animatic
then it was a year and a half to shoot
the live action portions
and get leslie's stall involved and get
you know create a live-action movie that
was just missing like basically the
central characters
and then we went into animation yeah so
we shot the movie twice so it's like
live-action shoot and then animation
shoot and you're basically like every
shot where marcel is in it you're
shooting that scene twice once for
plates and then once for animation and
it was like a year apart yeah
so and and are you um as director
present for all the animation shooting
or do you sort of let them go off on
their own to do
that sort of stuff yeah i was present
for all the animation shooting but i
don't know how other directors do it i
hear that that's yeah you were probably
more involved than i think most most
attracted to me i mean i thought it was
amazing like like dean and i went into
every single stage and like the both of
us met with the animators and like even
before that happened like we would talk
through every single shot and like kind
of had four years of it yeah
yeah first we did in storyboards and
then and then we did it like actually on
the stages before we got in there we
would like shoot little videos like
reference videos for animators or we
would and part of that was even just us
figuring out okay what exactly needs to
happen in the scene and you have to be
like
super super clear and direct with what
you want with the animators as well
because it's like most of the time you
get one shot like one take we didn't
have a lot of time to do more than one
take a lot of times
and a take takes all day for an animator
so you really don't want to have them
just aimlessly doing something that's
not right so we really meticulously
planned out like every subtle little
look and everything and then would just
communicate that to animators on stages
yeah there's a whole cut of this movie
that exists on our laptops that is just
me and kirsten acting out all the roles
yeah
yeah yeah there's that really fun one
that you posted recently where it's like
you being connie and me being marcel and
literally just the acting is like just
me being like
like that's it it's like super subtle
yeah
i mean and i was new to
i mean i'd done those like very crude
animations but basically new to
animation when this process began and
you realize that it's actually not so
different from directing actors except
that
you have the opportunity to sort of give
uh give an animator for example a
reference of facial expression so a lot
of the time you know it's like yeah
every blink every kind of subtle
movement on your face can be something
that they can take a cue from and like
oh that's where the that's where the
energy goes down that's where he takes a
breath all those minute things yeah yeah
things as small as like planning out
exactly where the blink should go uh was
really i mean because he doesn't have
much to he has an eye that blinks and he
has feet you know so there's like not
much else you can do so like we were
really really meticulous about like
where those things should go and what
plays best of comedy and stuff
yeah i feel like it takes like the
ultimate level of patience to do this
you guys are very zen
how many frames does it take for you to
know that an animator is wandering off
in the wrong direction
like like how many frames can you be
like no no no no no
i don't know hard to hard to totally
quantify it i mean it's yeah i mean we
do we do have like things called
cutbacks which we would try to avoid
doing like instead of doing a whole
retake sometimes
you know
you go in for a check-in maybe after a
few hours on an important shot and then
you take a peek at that point it's it's
a delicate balance of like you don't
want to piss animators off you know i
mean i'm an animator i wouldn't want
someone checking at me every hour be
like show me what you have now show me
what you have like well i only did 12
more frames in this hour you know so
it's like you know giving enough time
that like you can actually see something
that has some sort of shape to it and
then you know knowing like
yeah if it's if it's really you'll i
usually usually know if it's like okay
that's not that's not what we wanted
and then you know you can just do a
little cutback which is not a retake but
you just cut back a few frames enough
that you can kind of send it in the
other direction and it smoothly works i
can say from sort of a quasi-outsider
perspective that like kirsten has an eye
for that way before i do because
i think animators are like seeing the
matrix all the time
they're like that step forward there
means he's gonna have to circle all the
way back around later
yeah like chess you're seeing seven
moves
yeah yeah and you have to kind of have
this under like i've never took physics
but i have an understanding of physics
and the way things move in a way where
like you can break it down on a frame by
frame basis and understand like oh just
one more frame of anticipation before
you go forward is gonna give you
something funny whereas like if you
didn't have that anticipation it would
look robotic and it's like sometimes a
matter of like one or two frames
completely changes their performance the
the real feat to me of this movie i'm
sorry we've been talking for so long
no i'm just
we're getting real nerdy into the
animation you can't
you came here to tell how the movie was
made and you are so
uh i find it fascinating okay cool
and also i i just know how incredibly
difficult it is to make a movie like
this and and um congratulations to you
guys because it works so well it's such
a great thank you
i'm so i'm so curious i want to add i
want to ask about isabella rossellini
but also i want to ask you about a24
because and they're here they can
probably confirm is this the first kid
friendly a24 movie
other than the witch yes
kids love the witch
so much a lot of people at a24 have been
saying to me it's so nice i can show my
mom this movie finally i'm gonna show
her what we do for once
um well they're not up here to tell why
they chose this but you guys could you
guys talk about how from your
perspective about a24
why they chose it yeah oh
i don't know they're just like we're
going in another direction
we're not doing body horror
um i don't know i mean i think that they
are
i know they've been sort of branded as
like horror or whatever but they
actually i
feel like maybe don't get enough credit
for like you know
the other ones that are like
they don't fall into that niche so
they're maybe less
uh like eighth grade eighth grade or
minari or
mid 90s or like yeah you know moonlight
moonlight yeah
that's true i forgot about eighth grade
but i think that their their branding
the way that they've branded themselves
like really helps them you know support
a movie like ours that maybe wouldn't
cross over from the sort of uh whatever
we're in like art sphere or whatever
into arthouse into the mainstream and i
think that is
what defines a lot of their movies
or what they're really great at
isabella
yeah whose idea was its cast she was so
perfect for this
has she ever done voiceover work
before for a movie
i'm sure she's done some voiceovers we
didn't consider it if we didn't know
that she didn't know when we
she um we knew that she was an artistic
kook and that we wanted to build a
character around her but
partly i'm like the
the fact that she's so perfect for this
is because she's who she is and nick and
i got to write a character around what
was great about her
uh she really does live on a farm that
she maintains with some with help and
like actually you know has livestock she
has a um
masters and animal i saw your video you
posted it for bee sting
i watched it like 10 times her instagram
is amazing
she posted a video did she really get
stung by a bee i guess oh yeah she she's
posted a video where she's like putting
her face into the camera she's like look
how puffy this side of my face is
prepared
my my favorite instagram video of hers
is she's driving in her car and she
looks so delighted and she's got her
head out the window
and then she cries out like she's like a
war cry and then she turns the camera
and there's a rooster
and she's like in some sort of jousting
situation with the rooster in her car
and she's just having a ball it's
amazing she did a bizarre show on ifc
once so it wasn't called eco porn green
porno green porn it's so good if you
haven't seen it
for those who haven't seen it it's her
dressing up as different insects and uh
illustrating their mating rituals
it's a classic
um
i can't remember what all my questions
are talk amongst yourselves
well i was just gonna say i mean the the
character is so nick and i sort of had
the amazing privilege of being able to
write the character around
so nanakani existed and the plot was
generally the same but we there was so
much detail and specificity that she
brought to it that we
then because of our weird like we would
write write an edit for a few months and
then record for a couple days and then
write an edit
because of that we got to write around
what we found so great about her as a
person
she has a really wonderful grasp of
nature that's not romanticizing it
um but still revering its beauty
it's power yeah it's power is right yeah
um so you dean
are important part of this you play a
version of yourself for this
um who directs you
if you're the director
who directs dean you know i'm not really
an actor and i i've always wondered that
about like directors who are in their
own movies uh i don't know it's hard
actually one there were two days when um
leslie stall was on set that i brought
nick in to direct because i just knew i
was going to be occupied with that and
um so yeah it's nick that's me that's
the short answer
just pull in a guy off the street what
do you think of this
it's a safe pair of hands
do you feel when you were writing this
um
any pressure to to deal with real world
issues in the in the in the world of the
film like any pressure to deal with the
pandemic or any pressure to to basically
deal with
you know animation pulling any issues
anywhere sorry
pull any like real life yeah things
going on in the world politics right
there was definitely a temptation to do
that because like if you think about it
like the last seven years been so
you know full of
uh horrible horrible things in the world
and in our country that it was it was
sort of like hard not to a little bit
because you're like well i have a i
guess i'll have a platform in like three
more years maybe i should say something
about this
but ultimately i think the better
judgment was like
it's by that you can't be topical with
something like this or like animation
the animation like stop-motion you can
with south park or whatever but like
uh something that takes this long you
have to sort of
keep in mind that those issues or that
conversation will be so changed by the
time it comes out i remember there was
like a conversation about putting the
like
doing something about like kids in cages
as part of like the 60 minutes piece
that that leslie stahl was doing
and it was like
sure but whoa that sounds like a
terrible idea is that it come out now
you
the specificity of of talking about
something that's essential to human
nature
has been it's been really nice to have
people see the movie and be like this
movie's about the pandemic
and we wrote it way way before the
pandemic and recorded most of the audio
before the pandemic
and it's been a nice reminder that the
most evergreen thing is personal
experiences
told with specificity because then
people can be like that's my experience
right now in the pandemic or whenever
people watch this
yeah it's really interesting to me the
crossover in the themes
in this with with the pandemic like
loneliness
isolation
um which you probably had written the
script before
everything happened in 2020 so you
didn't know that was exactly gonna
happen we were shooting stop motion and
got shut down in 2020 like we were well
well into it yeah i mean i remember the
the stop-motion crew especially um
like feeling
feeling so happy to be working on a
project like this because you know a lot
of stuff in stop motion it's like robot
chicken not to knock it you know it's
it's cool in its own right but like
something like this i feel like that has
so much heart doesn't come along every
day especially like in the stop motion
sphere so like especially that crew like
i heard nothing but just like i don't
know just wonderful constant gushing of
like this is like giving us so much hope
through the pandemic we're so happy to
be working on this like this is it has
such a wonderful
you know at the heart of such a
wonderful sincere character and that was
so special even just for the people
working on it so that was really amazing
to see and you know the hope is like
that people will
you know will feel that as audiences as
well
do you think there's going to be a
marcel the shell sequel
in 10 years
[Laughter]
a very marcel christmas special
on cbs
um
i you know i don't know i mean hopefully
there's a market for it after the movie
comes out hopefully it does well i i
would love to further expand the world i
mean i know like kirsten and i like the
the actual community members
were sort of like at least from a macro
level an afterthought or like very done
towards the end where it was always like
yeah he reunites with his community
that's the ending
but we only flesh them out and like gave
them specificity towards you know in the
last like whatever couple years of
production and
just the last final three years
just squeaked it in
[Laughter]
well i'll be excited to interview you
guys for the sequel in 17 years
that's right
uh but but yeah i think now i feel like
oh my gosh there's this whole community
here that we created i want to know like
what is ghost tampon up to like what is
it
what is a pencil now somebody saw that
still i posted of ghost tampon and was
like
ha ha ghost tampon they
they called it the same name that we've
been calling ghost stamp on
[Music]
so i have to admit i thought that marcel
was a snail
and
uh i didn't realize until he found his
community and there were all kinds of
other animated inanimate like tampon
ghost taylor
i was like oh a show it's a show not it
was
not meant to be something that was like
even though it's freaking called marcel
the show
well you're actually i didn't realize
until like a couple years ago that he's
actually not a seashell he's a snail
show yeah me too yeah because we were
looking for family members yeah i didn't
know that until just now
he's a snail shell yeah he's a snail
shelter
wow i didn't we're open in mind
um i didn't get the pun in the name of
the beatles until like i was 32.
oh yeah me either
and i also didn't understand
um in wizard of oz that her throat that
her three uh uncles are cowardly
yeah yeah
i didn't realize that till i was an
adult you might have functional blood i
don't think i want to tell anybody that
i didn't know that
um
so there's some rumors going around
hollywood that this this took so long to
make because marcel is such a diva
is that really true or is is he just a
perfectionist
well i'm actually not an animator
there's a real living show and we
secretly filmed him but like don't tell
anyone
don't tell them whether it will really
become a real documentary
so this is um this is coming out this
week this friday
um the premiere is this saturday and
then uh it comes out in new york and la
on the 24th so the following friday
next friday is the answer to your
questions is it um next thursday day and
date uh thursday night next thursday
night i'm going it's really nice this
week from tonight is the opening
theaters and walmart selby at the oak
red carpet and opening night party
i mean you know he's got a tough agent
well thank you so much for coming and
talking thank you about this thank you
so much it's fabulous thank you guys for
coming
thank you to all of you marcel the show
with shoes on give it up again tell
everyone thank you and thank you to film
independent and thanks you guys for for
all coming out to see our movie yeah